hey this is presh talwalker here's a fun
logic puzzle my grandson is about as
many days as my son is weeks and my
grandson is as many months as I am in
years my grandson my son and I together
are 140 years
can you tell me my age in years
I thank unhud for the suggestion
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try
and when you're ready keep watching to
learn how to solve this problem
[Music]
so let's work this problem out step by
step
the first sentence is my grandson is
about as many days as my son is weeks
so there are three people in this
problem so let's set up variables for
each person
let's let M be equal to my age let s be
the sun's age and let G be the
grandson's age and we want all of these
ages to be in years
now my grandson is about as many days as
my son is weeks
so there are 365 days in a year so if
you take G and multiply it by 365 you
get about the number of days of the
grandson's age
so this will be 365 G
similarly there are 52 weeks in a year
so if we multiply s by 52 we get the
sun's age in weeks
now we know that my grandson is about as
many days as my son is weeks so these
two quantities are approximately equal
to each other 52s is approximately equal
to 365 G
now my grandson is as many months as I
am in years
so there are 12 months in a year so if
we multiply G by 12 we get the
grandson's age in months and that's
equal to my age in years so m is equal
to 12g
now my grandson my son and I together
are 140 years
so the sum of M S and G is equal to 140.
the objective of the problem is to tell
me my age in years so we want to solve
ultimately for the variable m
so let's just focus on these three
equations
so from 52s is approximately equal to
365 G
let's solve that s is approximately
equal to 365 divided by 52 multiplied by
G and that is approximately equal to 7g
so now we know s in terms of G and We
Know M in terms of G so let's substitute
in
let's substitute that m is equal to 12g
and we'll substitute that s is
approximately equal to 7g
so this equation becomes 12g plus 7g
plus G is equal to 140.
12g plus 7g plus G is equal to 20g and
that is equal to 140 so G is equal to
140 over 20 which equals 7 years
now m is my age that equals 12g so 12
times 7 is equal to 84. so my age is 84
years and that is the answer
thanks for making us one of the best
communities on YouTube see you next
episode of mind your decisions where we
solve The World's problems one video at
a time
foreign